[Music]
hello everyone i'm grand master dennis
porsche and this is insane in the end
game with some special games by
mr
carlson and ferrugia
now those two been vying for the top
spots for their rapid and blitz
championship
but for the first game i chose a game
where carlson was actually facing off
with duda now talking about the end
games and these two great players i have
to mention two big deals in chess
accuracy and tenacity the first one is
all about accuracy now
when we look at this game
between calls and john kristof duda we
have to start from the middle game we
can just go on in straight up the end
game because
the structure will decide how this game
will continue on
so i do want to invite you to take a
look
have your first impressions and tell me
what you think you see any targets for
duda any targets for calls
that should be the first thing you do
try to observe now the first thing that
would pop and pop and i could see with
my own eyes is the e5 pawn
actually pressing down in the middle
there making sure there is literally no
place to go to
for the opponent
now
apart from the fact that there is a
backwards d7 pawn it's actually not that
easy to go after that so our first goal
uh for all of you just joining
and everyone who have already joined
this little lecture how could we
potentially go after
that deep on or what sort of ideas would
come to mind
we already know it is there to stay it
can't go anywhere or we go all french on
it and go on passang
so
there are some basic ideas right now
we are not having enough pressure on it
so we gotta kind of mix it up
to have a chance at putting pressure on
duda
so any first thoughts how we could
pressure the d-pawn
now there are multiple ways of going
after that yeah i saw that someone
raised their hands
you yes sir
yep for sure
um how would you do that or how would
you go about it how would you double
gotta move that queen out of there
okay where
between e3 okay
and e3 makes sense yup
queen e3 is one way of playing any other
ways we could double yep go ahead
okay
rook he one i don't feel like that's
really doubling anything though uh
you could put it on
d3 eventually
correct so you could go rookie one
rookie three rook d3 like a long term
plan and actually carlson did something
very similar he did play queen to c3 not
to e3 and the reason for that choice is
that he was sort of scared that he'd
lose one of the a or c pawns
bishop e7
rook d3
very similar concepts instead of going
rookie 1 rookie 3 rook d3 he decides to
go in this direction queen e4 just
trying to be aggressive
g3
knight a5
now
here what actually plays this very very
strong move of rook d1 which i want to
point out because it is a game changer
if you go b3 already then there's knight
c6 and black is just in time to double
attack all those pieces so if you go
rook d1
knight b4 and you don't really have time
to take on d7 because there is knight
takes a to check and you lose the queen
therefore carlson goes rook d1 because
there is no time to lose and it's time
to attack that pawn over there rook d8
knight d2 over defending which of course
would have been possible earlier because
the rook on h1 was hanging
queen f5
rook f3 knight c6
bam
took the pawn it's game over i mean so
would we think
but
in fact duda has a tricky tricky ploy up
his sleeve
very very sneaky move what sneaky move
did jan kristof have in mind
it looks like we're winning a pawn for
free but it is just not so
chad is saying that they wanted to send
me a pie but they didn't know where to
send it
st louis chess club
you put a beautiful signature there for
dennis
and trust me i'll do my best
knight d4
and 94
i believe is some sort of an oversight
for carlson it looks like there's no way
out of here if you take on f5
knight e2 check
and suddenly
the hunter gets hunted you lose the
exchange
you're facing this tripled pawn this
isn't gonna get pretty
however
if you play your first 20 25 moves
correctly even an oversight
isn't going to cause too much trouble
and carlson actually found the best way
he could liquidate in this position so
let's try to find the best way of
playing even though he may have
had this missed
we did want to triple on the d file
but
then black started to harass us with the
queen on e4
queen d4 exactly
so
noticing that there is no way out if you
move the rook you lose the piece
if you take we already discussed then
there's 92 checked and you lose material
so the best and only way you can
continue on is queen takes d4
pawn takes
rook ticks
bishop ticks
so what is the pawn count and piece
count at the moment
and this is actually very very crucial
white does have a handful of pawns but
what do you guys think is it enough
is it more than enough
so i'm looking for raised hands yep go
ahead white has a knight
yep do you think it's enough is it
better for white um
i think it's in africa
it's enough for carlsen
so i know that there is a lot of love
for carlsen
but the last i checked chess is an
objective game
so
if we forget about that white is causing
which is correct
do you think it's better for white
even
a little bit better for black
yeah good the uh the doubles on islands
just seem impossible to
defend
these guys
okay
so it's a little bit early to say that
we're winning there's still a lot of
work to do as we'll see
um
but
you'd rather claim it's better i guess
okay yes i saw a hand
i think it's better
yep that's a very good point and one of
those things that i always ask students
and people who i'm working with
always look at the nature of the
structure
and here as you pointed out correctly
one has a past h pawn a protected h pawn
which will prove useful towards the end
so
bishop takes
what happened okay so queen f3 happened
my bad
knight takes c takes bishop takes g7
rotates seven so he actually luckily
avoided that so he doesn't have those
doubled pawns
bishop f6 trades trades rook h6 takes
rook takes f6
f4
now whenever you get into an ending
and you kind of feel that you're the one
trying to press for victory
there is a tendency on these super gm
games that are trying to go for safety
so with that in mind what sort of moves
would come to your heads and minds
for white how could we over defend our
position
f4 is actually the first step in that
direction
yeah go ahead
knight e2
over defending this currently weak g
pawn and that g pawn
is actually crucial because it over
defends the h and f and if that's
defended we do not need to worry
anything else
or on the other side is there anything
else that we could do and work on
well
we could still go something like b2 to
b3 and a4
just over defending on this side of the
board as well
so king e7 rook d3 over defending
rook c8 b3
so
we've seen
an interesting sequence of moves with
this knight d4 queen takes d4 queen
takes f3
and we get a dynamic position and the
first thing causing does is over
protection making sure that he will run
no risk whatsoever
rogue g6 very good move by
the local polish player
going after the g-pawn
knight e2
over defending
rook g8
now this is again
after over defending our pawns
the second to last step is to come up
with a plan
now if you're trying to come up with a
plan
there's two sides that we can play on
because we've got a majority here we've
got a two to zero advantage
like these pawns really don't have
anyone in front of them apart from those
rooks of course
and we also have got some advantage on
the queen side so for now we have to
decide which side of the board we want
to play
and if you're the fan of
aliogen
well we may even do both
you want the king towards a6 well i also
have dreams
but
yeah
that seems a little far-fetched is this
live no this is pre-recorded
the audience everything they said is
pre-recorded
any reaction they're doing that was also
pre-recorded laughs we've got a laugh
track
so yeah um welcome to this show that is
kind of live
kind of
not so with that in mind i mean this
position in mind
um
which way we could try to progress
why would we bring that king to f3 so we
can move our rook around maybe
yep
that is very good
that is the plan you want to do you want
to march up with the king
and just join the battle
but that still doesn't really tell me
which side of the board you want to play
although
i kind of
getting the hint
getting the hint but i still don't know
what your plan is
yes go ahead i mean i think our uh our
age pawn is a
huge asset that we just need to keep
pushing forward
um
yes
good question
not even a question that's a statement
what i'm saying uh
yeah we want to push that h-bond
but if we do it a bit early it's gonna
get snatched
just taken from us
so
actually you could combine those two
plants you could go king d2 king e3 king
f3
and then push it like yasir would
with h5 and g4 but it's very important
that we have our king on f3 first
if you go h5 now rotate 6 and you don't
have time to over protect that g pawn
king d2
d6 a4
and as i said earlier
carlson isn't really playing on the
queen side you guys actually predicted
it well you want to play on this side of
the board
instead of the queen side but he makes
sure that there is no potential b5
breaks
making sure the coast is clear
exactly trying to go for a risk-free
situation e5 now duda is not the patient
type if you ever seen duda play he
always go for the most aggressive
continuations
he's not that karpovian player you'd get
used to rook f3 again over defending if
pawn takes you capture back with daruk
and even if you capture here you
sacrifice that's just not enough white
still has an extra pawn
rook g4
king e3
king e6 king f2
all right so
wine has this fairly straightforward
plan
of going rook d3 king f3 and h5
how could black try to sort of sabotage
that idea
and hint nudge nudge dude i didn't do
that
so there was actually a better way of
defending
for black
and that's a question for you too chad
not just the audience over here
so
black wants to go e4 here okay
so the idea that we're looking for for
jan kristoff
is more of
a defensive measure
what is trying to go here
wants to go king f3 wants to go h5
but for h5 to work we've got to go with
g4 right
if we can't play g4
we ain't gonna be able to start rolling
that's the hint that's that
f5 exactly so that's the move he didn't
play but really should have
if he gets the pawn on f5
i'm not claiming that duda wouldn't have
lost the game probably is still worse
but the plan
involving any sort of palm pushes on the
king set sort of dies down
it probably is going to be a long battle
but with much much better chances for
duda to hold
he instead played rook g7
duda is going for what is called the
waiting tactic
saying i don't know what you're going to
do but my position is solid
but to quote someone kind of related to
this game
he doesn't believe in fortresses
does he
so he went rook e3 king f5 rook d3 just
slowly probing away
king e6
rook d5 again just probing a bit
rook g8 he's saying
[Music]
you shall not pass
king f3 he's slowly improving on the
situation
getting the king up now the reason i
wasn't a huge fan of that e4 move that
would give away that d4 spot for the
knight
a6
rook d1
king e7
all right new situation
new problems
now
whenever we've been thinking about this
h5 idea
it doesn't really work just yet because
they can still go f5
so we got to look for a different way of
playing
you got to look for
new ideas new weaknesses yes go ahead
could you just start pushing the h
um as i said
if we push the h pawn they're gonna go
f5
and there is still some disconnect
between rg and h
and those g and h pawns they're like
brotherly tanks they want to move
forwards together
not separately it gots to be a convoy
maybe try to get our knight to a more
useful square okay
like maybe f5 or d5
so
is there any
kind of problems that we face at the
moment to get that knight to d5
uh yeah we'll lose our g pawn yep
so we gotta think about ways maybe you
could prepare it
maybe rip g1
yeah j1 could make some sense
i guess the problem is if you go rook g1
king e6
if you go knight c3 then i can take on
f4
and then there's just too much pressure
on the rook
so that means pushing the h pawn
doesn't work rook g1 doesn't work
okay
now when i said look for weaknesses in
black's camp
i was actually telling the truth
look at those pawns on d6 and b6
they're pretty much weak over there
um
how can we come and try to inch closer
potentially
you can yes
you can go a5 for sure
any other ideas
c5 i just capture i don't really see
what's the point there
yeah definitely you can go for a5 try to
weaken those pawns just go after these
but actually carlson went for the other
push with f5
and his point is he's going to go for f6
trading off
this pawn for the d-pawn and then he
goes full pac-man style on the a6 and b6
so check
here
takes
takes now if you do nothing i'm going to
go for a5 or f6 and in a port 2 moment
and just start picking pawns one by one
so king f6 takes takes rook takes b6
rogue g6
all right
question number one
is trades good for us
yeah not really
but we could
soften and sweeten the deal for us and
this position is
white we don't necessarily want to trade
unless
on our terms go ahead
and he says you know we can trade
if you trade well sign me up bob c5
and then we may even get this very
unique tetris pawn formation
which you won't have any ways of getting
close to and slowly but surely you're
going to lose once those pawns start
marching down
so he decided not to take there played
rook d8
g4
takes
but yeah rook d8 unfortunately for black
already loses because of the king's
unfortunate situation
rook takes
knight g3 check
the king has no place to go to
we gotta take
king takes g3 e4
okay
so
objectively we're winning this position
no problems
but is there any still any sort of
problems that we still have to figure in
this position
black still has one last trick up his
sleeve one last trick
yeah good well he's got two connected
past pawns but i don't think they're
fast enough
yeah that is correct so they still have
a pass pawn running down the board
so you got to find a way
to stop him
well
we are going to go
and go in front of it
go king f2
block it that's the easiest way to stop
all these pass pawns just move your king
in front of it f5
a6
now of course it's getting a little bit
tighter but
this is already on the sixth while these
pawns are only on the fifth
and the fourth
i mean this is the fifth that's the
fourth
king f4
rook e6
getting behind that pawn stopping
black from achieving the same thing
rook here
c5 just trying to stop that pawn both
directions
rook d7
rook d6 not
actually allowing black to get on in
there
rook here
rook d4
so what could be the idea behind rook d4
if we think about it
it's actually a multi-purpose move yes
yeah it hinders this pawn on e4 but
there is another idea behind it
which makes it so good yeah
yeah so not only do you stop your
opponent from rolling you're also
preparing either rk-4 running the a-pawn
or running the c-pawn
which is of course the decisive idea in
this position
king e5
rook a4
f4 a7 and this pawn is just too fast
e3
king f1
and here black resigned you might be
surprised to see this king d5 move but
that is of a dgd poor
dgt board special
kings often are put on the color of the
winner so that's why they move the king
to d5
and if black would try f3
we'd promote
e2 check we're of course going to go
king f2 it's never too late by the way
to lose a winning position king e1 will
lose immediately to check and promotion
so
a famous women's world champion
kostenyuk once said that chess is all
about paying attention even at the last
moment where duda resigned you could
still lose the game
so here you have to go king f2
check king takes f3 just making sure
promotion doesn't happen with a check
but talking about checks we would give a
check on e8 and we win the game
and it's game over
so that actually means
that carlson even though he did an
oversight early on
he actually managed to outplay his new
rival john kristoff who's actually in
the candidates already and
probably
can be potentially one of the challenges
for magnus later on
but talking about big challengers
we still yet to take a look at two other
games
one still featuring carlson and the
other one featuring ferruja
so let me start off with this one by
fiorugia we're not going to start from
the beginning
we are going to go from this position
queen f4 check straight from the ending
now
if you look at the position it's clear
that firouja is the one pressing for the
win
in the earlier game we saw between
carlson and duda
that accuracy goes a long way but in
other cases
it's tenacity that wins you the chess
game so queen takes f4
rook takes f4
in this game firuja wins the pawn all
right so
any time you get into a new position you
got to observe
whose pieces are better
what are potential problems for each
side so let's start with that
whose king is better
who has
potentially bigger problems in this
position
apart from obviously the fact that white
is upper pawn
is probably better
yep white's king is much much better
because this king
on g8 is cut off
that is actually one of the most
important details
in rook end games if a king is cut off
ninety percent of the time you are just
losing
based on the fact that the king cannot
participate and even if the pawn marches
up to a7 it's a winning position because
you can't avoid the background check
so a5
king g3 trying to activate his king so
the first thing you do in these endings
is either trying to win the pawn which
would have been another option like
going rogue b5
trying to pick that pawn or activating
your own king
rook d4
row k7 going after that eight pawn here
takes rook takes b2
and even though we alluded a little bit
earlier or where the rooks ought to be
are the rook placements good for white
absolutely not this rook on a5
is probably
kind of not enjoying their stay on a5
it'd rather be on a1
supporting it from behind and then the
wind would be crystal clear but with the
rook on a5 it's hindering that pawn
from moving forward and if you ever move
away you will have to face all these
checks and struggle because of that
so he goes through k7 keeps this king at
bay
or k2
okay
so now we've got to go for plans
one of the biggest problems
if we're sort of new to a rookie end
game is that we want to play it quick
because oh there's just so few pieces
and material left it should be trivial
no we should take our time and come up
with the best concept we possibly can
what would be the most ideal formation
for white
got to decide how far we are going to
push that a pawn if we're going to push
it at all
would you go h4 here
h4 yeah h4 seems very reasonable you're
fixing these pawns so that's a good move
any thoughts about the a pawn though
yeah go ahead
how far that's the of course you're
gonna push it but how far
congratulations that's the answer you
want to promote your pawn
correct
um unfortunately we've got that
a rook in the way
and if you move that away you lose the
pawn
but uh yeah
well you want to push it as far as you
can
but should you push it till a7
or a6
i mean those are the most viable options
at the moment
the black king is tied down to g7 and h7
mm-hmm and then you can
activate
a6 why a6 why not a7
um
well i think you can just push it to the
sixth like or something so you bring
your white king in and hide or something
correct
so
we'd love to go till a7 the only problem
with going to a7 i'm just gonna make
some moves here
if you go to lay seven
you're trapping my king but you're also
trapping your rook so it's all about the
activity of your pieces and how bad my
pieces get
and even if you would walk this king up
till b7
i will be
the annoying sister
and chase you away from the computer
check
you thought you're gonna play nope
you come closer
well that's not my preferred square but
if you go here check again and i'll keep
checking you until you move away and i
go back here
and unfortunately this is just not quite
enough
for you to win the game now if there
were loose ends like a loose pawn on f6
you could walk your king over there
take that pawn and win the end game but
you always have to have a second
weakness in this position if you want to
push the pawn up to a7
so let's just go back
to the game continuation h4 was played
but indeed you usually want to push that
pawn to a6 for one you keep that king at
bay for second your king might have a
hiding square behind that a pawn
so rook c2
a4 rook c4 that's again a very very
smart defense by shefchenko
who's a very strong grandmaster in his
own right he's making sure the king
cannot pass
a5
check
g5 trying to trade as much as possible
takes a6
king g3 rook a4 again cutting off the
king
king f3 now
the good thing for firuja is that he can
walk that king over there you don't have
time to take this pawn
for example
let's say i go here
king e3 here i already have this move
and it's winning as i said earlier you
go a7 and because of the unfortunate
nature of your king's position i will
have this winning because if you go here
i'm just in time to check and promote
so rook takes here here king f3 king f8
king e3
g3
king is walking there
so it kind of
will act as a defender sort of releasing
this rook so he can just trade on the
other side
king here
a7 check
king g5
king h4 and now firuja decides to
abundant the a pawn
takes takes
king c6
g4 king d6
rook f5
now here actually furuja makes a mistake
you can cut off a king
from the side but you can also cut them
vertically with rotate 6 and go g5 and
the thing is if you go here then i check
again
and if you don't do that like you go
down i go king h5 go king g6 and again
you are not able
to stop me my king cuts you off
and once i go king g7 g6 it's game over
so people tend to forget
that apart from the standard cutting off
of the king you can also cut him off
this way as well
which would be also a winning position
um did i see a raised hand there or
stretching okay that's also good
so
rook f5
king e6 king h5
here
rook f1
and actually
this is already
a drawn position
so it's black to move
and force a draw
and the problem is you can go forward
you got to defend that pawn
whatever you do even if you go king h5 i
check again
and you're forced back
so he moves back king g3
rook g8 rook f5
rk8
king f4 rook b8 still just waiting
there's nothing you can do g5 and again
the funny part about chess that even if
you're up a pawn in a rookhand game you
can still lose it
it has single inattention
chess is probably one of the cruelest
game apart from tennis
that one mistake we'll do
from a great situation
to the worst one
of course we're talking about firuja
here now the position is objectively
drawn right now
and what firuja does
is
being tenacious so he keeps on trying
keeps trying different formations until
his opponent fatigues
king g3 rk8 again a good move attacking
on the sides keeping options open
rook f4
rook g8
king h4 and here actually shivchenko
makes
a big big mistake
but here black could still hold
and because of this mistake actually
chefchenko instead of holding loses
and i go king h6
and if i go rook f5
just go back
and if i go king h5
so here here here
so king e5 was crucial because at this
moment the rook is over defending the
g-pawn
checking is actually pointless because
that is already protected so black had
to move out of that rook
now you move it away and now just
checking and it's a trivial draw
but unfortunately for shevchenko
he checked
king h5 and this is already lost
as okay he still goes back again but
this time he makes it correctly
so i guess
second time around is a charm
king e5 rookie 4n sadly enough you have
no ways of stopping the g-pawn
and that's why these end games are so
ruthless one mistake is good enough and
it's gone
check king g7
check
g5
and again
your king is just cut off and there's
nothing you can do check
king g8 pawn is a comment
check
here
check
rook h8
and he is building that good old bridge
king here and of course it's resigns
even if you go here
here here rook h7 and it's a game over
you can't stop that g pawn from
promoting
so the first game we saw was accuracy
second game is about tenacity and if you
thought that causent cousin cannot be
tenacious well you're wrong
in fact in the very first game of the
rapid tournament he had to
show his skills so let's take a look at
this one
we are going to
fast forward
to a critical moment
we're gonna take a look from this
position
okay seven
check king e eight
and
objectively causin doesn't really have
an advantage he has a pull he has a
little bit of an attack
the king again incidentally is cut off
so he plays against it goes king e5
rook takes c2 rook c7
and um
as jonathan rosson a very very famous
grandmaster
put it
cousin is
metalsome
and he always comes up with a very very
tricky idea
so even though objectively white is not
better but he is posing some questions
how are you going to defend this pawn
how are you going to defend this bomb
now if black actually would lose the g
pawn what would get true winning chances
so rookie 2
rook e4
but gaganosh really actually is
defending very well he says well if you
can take the g pawn i'm going to take
your
and that actually happens takes king g5
rook f1 rook takes c6
so let's just observe here for a split
second
any potential problems
in black's position or any targets that
cause and can latch onto
yep
could try but if you do
then black goes knight g3 and we trade
so you actually don't have enough there
because the knight will sacrifice itself
for the pawn and that's a known drawn
position
well there is this b-pawn
on b5 that white can go after
but also another idea that this knight
is somewhat loose
you can't ever really go in it seven
because of rookie six plans and threats
you can't really go in ig7
because knights are
famously not good fion shadowed
so
knight is sort of the culprit of this
position and the b-pawn
so narcoson is going to start pushing
against those king d7 rogue b6 first off
he goes for the b pawn
knight g3 of course he doesn't want to
trade many pieces so checks
rook e6
so instead of taking the pawn
he forced black to go knight g3 and now
he changes tac
what he's trying to do is to box in this
knight on g3
right now you can't go to e4 you can't
go to e4
i mean to e2 and e4 excuse me and
even though objectively black is still
fine
time is ticking
they're already in blitz mode
and gagonashvili still has to be
accurate
king d7 rookie 5.
so he's not trying to win-win the
position he's trying to put pressure on
the black player
rook f3 king g4 all these moves are just
trying to push gagonashvili off the
board
rook b3 king f4
not a single threat just saying okay
probably it's still a draw but what are
you going to do
you can't go here i take you can't go
there i take you
king c6 a good move and
props for gaganashvili to holding on
here he's not trying to make like big
sweeping moves
he's waiting he's saying okay
this should be objectively even so i'm
not in a rush to make a decision
rookie 6
rookie 5.
king c6 bishop f2
again
giving the option
for gagonashvili to take on b4 and then
you get into this torture chamber that
bishop brook versus rook which
objectively is drawn
but it takes some effort to hold
but actually maybe it would have been
the right time to do it because
then you know that for certain i'm going
to have to defend this ending and
probably black could just set up the
right construction
push give up this b-pawn and just hold
from there
because
you're going to see he's going to get
into a construction which isn't as easy
to hold
so bishop f2 not f1 keeps the knight
bishop e1
changes the placement but for a reason
he's going to defend the b-pawn from the
e1 square while the same time eyeing the
g3
look at that this knight has only one
more square left
started out on f5
completely mobile and defendable now
this 9 on f1 is actually running out of
space
not h2
rook c5 bishop c3 not only is he closing
off this knight he's also closing off
this rook on g3 i mean b3
knight f1 bishop e1
king e4
and he's slowly inching up closer and
now remnants of mating ideas with bishop
f2 rook c7 is showing up
knight c4
king d4
rook b1 bishop c3 check
here knight d6 check and it's still
nothing it's still not a huge advantage
it is still very much symbolic probably
he could try to go rook d6 and then go
knight b6 but i guess gagonash really
thought that i'm off the hook by now
nothing's going to happen
check
rook d3 bishop e1 knight c4 and suddenly
the bishop does show up and now it's
getting dangerous you go king
there
i might as well start threatening that
rook c7 idea
like here rook c7 and it's getting
dangerous
you played king b7 rather gave up the
pawn
king a6
knight d6 king e5
knight f7
check
knight d8
b5
still very drawish but it's progress he
got the extra pawn
and the king is also a little bit
cornered
rook d2 and note that he also played
this
b4 to b5 move to take away that square
bishop e3
rookie 5.
again
over defending everything very similar
for like the duda game he's making sure
that everything is guarded king c7 rook
e4
check
rook c3
again he is not trying to do anything
spectacular he's saying you just don't
have a move
and now gagonash really goes here bishop
b6 and gaganash really had enough
and this is the moment i can tell you
that he sort of made a decision early on
that was wrong he should have gone into
that rook bishop versus rookhand game
while he could choose the formation and
just defend sturdily from then on
because now the king is somewhat
uncomfortable or ready
king b7 king d6
again you don't have a check
bishop e7
king e6
bishop d6 inching ever so closer
king b5 rook c5 check of course can go
king b4 due to rook d5 and you lose the
rook
king b6 king d7
rook here rook c2
check
there bishop d4 again cutting off the
rook
bringing the king closer and then
eventually you want to give that check
pushing that king
to the
first rank there which
i mean it gets a little bit complicated
because by now you can also rotate the
board it's the same thing
here check
king d5 and again if you check i go
bishop d4 with the same idea of rook b2
check
there
check and you're forced
to the a file
king d6
check king c7
bishop d6 so far good defense by black
king c6
bishop c5 but already you can sort of
feel the tension
the king is sort of running out of space
you can't go here obviously because you
got mated in one
you can't really go here
because of here and you lose your rug
go here you lose the rook
so you played
king a4
rook b4 check
and now tragedy struck
he had to play king a5
and still
is
it's a torture but he's probably still
having chances of holding
but he played king a3 and that directly
ran into rook b1 check
and it's game over
so what did we learn from this game we
learned that even in an even position a
position that is equal you have chances
to win the game
if you make it hard for your opponent to
come up with a clear-cut plan
conversely on the other side gagonash
really should have tried for a more
crystal clear plan to hold the position
so i really hope all of you enjoyed this
lecture on the accuracy the art of
accuracy by carlson and ferugia and how
tenacity can somehow net you some juicy
juicy points thank you so much for
watching thank you
[Music]
you